one of the great things I think about 60
symbols Brady is that we've been doing
them for a while now and we've covered
quite a new a few topics and of course
it's not that you do a video about a
topic and then everyone who's
researching into that topic says oh
there's a 60 symbols video let's not
work on it anymore they carry on there
was an update by the ligo Consortium
these are this this amazing group of
experiments which were the first direct
detection of gravitational waves and the
consequences of this has opened up a new
field of astronomy really which we can
call multi-messenger astronomy which we
can describe the first observation was
in 2015 and then by 2017 its
significance was recognized enough to
get three of them Nobel prizes so we're
heading on for six years on they've
released their third set of data they've
now got 90 events which might not sound
like a lot given that you've been
analyzing things for six years but when
you realize the majority of these events
are from colliding black holes so black
holes which have been orbiting each
other and then collided together merged
if you like coalesce is the technical
term produce gravitational waves waves
ripples in the space time of our
geometry which they've then propagated
out and arrived at these detectors
if I tell you it's taken over a billion
years basically for each of these events
to arrive at our detector it kind of
gives you a feel for okay these are very
sensitive detectors
[Music]
they're fairly rare events but the fact
that they've managed to go from one in
2015 up to actually they've reported on
35 in their last run which was from
November 2019 to March 2020. so shows
you that they're ramping up that they're
getting their detectors sort of they're
homing in on how to get them as precise
as possible they're reducing all the
possible errors and their sensitivities
are increasing
and we're finding some really quite
beautiful results emerging and I thought
I'd just sort of try and give an update
on where I think we are with it and
maybe just a little reminder of what
ligo is so ligo there's the ligo and
Virgo are the two main detectors there's
ligo has got two detectors themselves in
America one in Louisiana and one in
Washington state each of the detectors
are made up of two arms which are about
four kilometers long they call they're
called an interferometer laser beams are
shown up and down each of these arms
with Incredible accuracy so at the end
of each of the arms there's mirrors and
these mirrors are suspended in such a
way they're they basically are in free
fall they don't feel the seismic
vibrations or the thermal fluctuations
or the experiments can handle all of
these potential problems they have but
the laser beams bounce off the mirrors
and the idea and then they they
recombine them so one set of laser beams
has gone down one arm and the other set
has gone down the other arm and then
they bring them back and recombine them
and they look for path differences
and they set it up initially so that
there's there's no path difference and
then the idea is if a gravitational wave
a distortion of the space time comes by
it will distort one of these ever so
slightly
and then you'll see these two beams will
have passed a different distance from
one another and they'll pick up an
interference pattern and just to give
you an idea of the sensitivity these
these lasers are traveling four
kilometers the Distortion that we expect
to arrive from these gravitational waves
which just to remind you of typically
come from a pair of black holes which
have been orbiting each other a billion
years ago coalesced together it's been
traveling for a billion years at the
speed of light pass through the detector
it distorts the Detector by 10 to the
minus 21 centimeters the size of a
proton
is 10 to the minus 18 centimeters this
is a thousand times less than the the
radius of a proton
so the the sensitivity of this
experiment is quite staggering and so
there's one in Louisiana there's one in
in Washington state and there's one in
um Italy there's a new one that has just
come on board in Japan as well making
four sets of detectors in the next
decade there's going to be one coming in
in India let's stick with the two in the
US what they look for is if this
gravitational wave has come in say and
hit the one in Louisiana
then they don't interact with anything
they just carry on through they start in
the space-time ever so small and then it
will eventually go through the one in
Washington state and so what they they
the detectors look for is joint events
they look for the same signal
from that signal they have two ways then
of determining what they're finding they
have a bank of what you call templates
these are like images
that they have already calculated that
they know what certain objects should do
what the signal should look like so two
black holes merging they know what they
should look like two neutron stars
merging they think they know what that
should look like a black hole in a
neutron star merging together they think
that what that they know what that
should look like so they then compare
these images to these templates and by
then tweaking the parameters of the
models for the templates they can see
which best fits the data and that's how
they've been able to give so much
information about the black holes but
they've got another way which I had
forgotten about and this other way is
imagine there's out there an object
which we haven't yet discovered and deep
down I know Brady that the real reason
you've got into this is that you do have
your own style let's call it the Brady
on the bradyon style it's a compact
object we've yet to see it and in
particular we don't yet know what
happens when two bradyons collide
together
so they have this other way that so the
ligo people say don't worry Brady we'll
find it and what they look for is a
second way of analyzing the data is they
just look for the synchronicity of of
the events coming through
and if the events that go through
Washington State and ligo and and
Louisiana look very similar to one
another then they can take them out and
begin to probe look look at those events
themselves they don't need the templates
and from it eventually they'll they'll
probably have to wait for a second Brady
OnStar merger to occur they'll be able
to sort of infer we've got some new
thing out there and that's what one of
the things they're doing they look for
unexpected events that we don't yet know
what what are forming them aren't there
particles called radions have you got
your own particles as well there already
are bradions I've been wanting to ask
you about them for years
another day we better look them up so of
course we had the first detection of the
of in 2015 which was phenomenal in its
own right in 2017 they then discovered
and we've we have discussed this briefly
but I think it's worth mentioning they
discovered their first case of neutron
stars merging together and what was so
important about that is when black holes
merge together the only thing that sort
of produced as gravitational waves that
propagate out but neutron stars are full
of neutrons and so when they merge
together you not only produce
gravitational waves from the from the as
you distort the space time with the
great masses of the of the neutron stars
but because they've got neutrons in
there you produce electromagnetic
radiation as well and so now what you
can look for is detecting both the
electromagnetic radiation the
gravitational waves and one of the key
results that came from this 2017
observation was that the the
gravitational waves and the
electromagnetic radiation the x-rays
arrived sort of on on Earth in fact
there was a satellite just above Earth
detecting the elect the x-rays within
1.7 seconds of each other so they've
been traveling for 300 million years to
get to us
so to arrive within 1.7 seconds over
that distance means that these two waves
are traveling at the same speed or
extremely close to the same speed that
had the knock-on effect of ruling out a
whole load of cosmological models of
modified gravity which we're trying to
understand the acceleration of our
universe by modifying general relativity
and in this one observation whoosh so
there were some theories that were
saying that the gravitational waves and
the electromagnetic waves should have
been traveling at different space
exactly and one of them was ours The Fab
Four was one of them oh you lost it you
lost a theory before I went yeah we made
a video about that one we did you'll
have to just bend that one now it's a
nice idea I think I really think it's
quite a nice idea it may all collapse
that's the nature of research so they've
carried on of course making more
observations and the most recent sets uh
they announced 35 new candidates there's
a beautiful picture you can see that you
of the black holes and of of that it's
not it's a diagrammatic representation
of what's Happening of those 35
candidates 32 a black hole black holes
orbiting each other and coalescing
within that there's some really
interesting features one of them that's
that's got people quite excited is that
they're beginning to see black holes of
large black holes masses of order 60 70
solar masses
coalescing together and they're
beginning to see these what are known as
intermediate scale Mass black holes and
no one really understands how they form
and so and but they're beginning to see
them in more abundance
even though the the they're looking at
you know they've got 90 events or so the
rate at which they're beginning to see
them is already pushing some of the
recognized models of intermediate black
hole formation to to their limits
they're also seeing some very light
black holes merging together and there's
a really interesting property of black
holes which I hadn't really thought
about
black holes of course are regarded as
being a so mass is not much above a
solar mass a few of six five six solar
mass black holes merging together
it turns out the black holes ex change
the curvature of the space times that's
why we talk about black holes as being a
great laboratory to test general
relativity because we can test the
strong curvature regime and you might
think to yourself that means you must
look at the really biggest black holes
they're going to have the biggest impact
but actually they don't the black the
curvature are the compact object is
inversely proportional to the mass of
the object so the smaller the mass the
bigger the curvature so if you really
want to test strong gravity you want
light black holes actually merging
together the really big black holes the
really massive black holes by the time
you're out at the Event Horizon of the
black hole the curvature is actually
quite quite low and so you're not really
testing the very strong regime so
they're seeing evidence of that and then
the other thing that they're seeing
evidence of which I think is really neat
now is that for the first time they're
seeing evidence of neutron stars and
black holes merging together
it's a snack
you see yes I think it's a snack I think
you'll see in the black hole snacking on
the neutron star so they've got one in
particular which they they think is
really fascinating it's a 30 soul and
mass black hole and there's a 1.2 solar
mass neutron star that's just sort of
being merged into it eaten by it and and
that's at the very border of when a
neutron star can form but the hope there
is that that also because it's a neutron
star will be able to give out
electromagnetic radiation so you'll be
able to test you know the merge of
properly you know how what happens as
the object goes across the Event Horizon
and what can you tell from the form of
the of the waves that have been produced
another thing that they're finding which
I think is really interesting is that
black holes have associated with them
certain characteristics the mass is one
of them the spin is another one and it's
charged does it have any charges another
what they've now finding sort of pretty
concrete evidence for in a number of the
mergers is that the the black holes that
are emerging have spin associated with
them and that's particularly interesting
those are called Kerr black holes and
what's particularly interesting about
that is that because you've got a bit
more information now about the spin of
the black hole whether it's spinning
quickly or spinning slowly then you've
got some information that you can
compare with your theories because
different theories
will predict different spins of black
holes depending on where the black holes
formed by objects passing by each other
really rapidly then you can imagine
they'll have a lot of spin associated
with the more angular momentum or
whether they just simply objects merging
together when you you won't expect much
and so by looking at the distribution of
the spins we're once again going to be
able to test
theories of black hole formation another
element which they've got very good data
on is first of all the distance scale
out to these objects and as I said black
holes are typically finding black holes
at orders of Giga parsecs remember I
said a pass X3 light years this is of
order 3 billion years the light's been
traveling the Earth was forming around
the time when some of these coalescent
objects were were meeting one another
it's just so remarkable that we can get
death like this another thing that is of
interest to people who are trying to
understand the nature of black holes and
their merging is if two black holes come
together what's the likelihood that
they're near equal masses as opposed to
one being completely dominant over the
other and they're able to get that kind
of information out of this as well so
you know I hope you get the impression
there's a lot going on there and the
there's a lot for the theorists to sort
of mull over and get into to try and
understand this amazing area and the
future is just mind-blowing as to what
we'll be able to do as they upgrade the
detectors we'll be able to see D print
of the universe if you see D print of
the universe just imagine a cone coming
out from you and going deeper and deeper
and deeper you see more and more of the
sky so you can see more and more events
and then you'll eventually begin to be
able to probe early Universe phenomena
that's that's the hope that we might be
able to see evidence of phase
transitions in the early universe or
something that I would love is if we saw
any evidence of cosmic strings emitting
their gravitational waves so that's one
of the things Advanced ligo is still
looks for that's called the stochastic
background of radiation and now with the
the Japanese gravitational wave detector
coming on board and the Indian one in in
the next decade having more and more
detectors just means that you've got
better resolution as to where the
gravitational wears are formed from and
this is going to have an absolutely
amazing impact eventually because
there's a thing out there called the
Hubble tank attention we've spoken about
the Hubble tension that's this idea the
universe is expanding
and if you measure the expansion rate
using distant measurements like the
cosmic micro background you get one
value if you measure the expansion rate
using supernovae which are closer you
get another value and these two values
are not overlapping
both of those processes rely on you
understanding the cosmology of the
system some to estimate the Luminosity
distance to these objects this method
with gravitational waves doesn't do that
all the information is wrapped up in the
signal that we get and so as long as you
can pinpoint how far away the object is
and actually the polarization of the
light then actually
the expansion rate of the universe will
pop out it will come out it'll be a
direct measurement it'll probably the if
they can get enough data enough objects
to test it'll be within a few years a
one percent few percent measurement of
the Hubble expansion rate which will be
a massive feature and there's so many
other things that are out there waiting
to be detected it's a this whole period
of gravitational wave and
multi-messenger exploration is fantastic
why is it called multi-messenger because
it will so it will this is
multi-messenger means when there's two
sets of waves at least two sets
different sorts gravitational waves and
electromagnetic waves those are the two
usual multi-messenger but it could also
be neutrinos for example being emitted
which get will get emitted when neutron
stars collide together you told me
before about how
subtle and small the signal received is
just this tiny tiny
deviation in this laser caused by the
gravitational waves
and presumably also sometimes a little
bit of light or x-rays sometimes as well
on the other hand you tell me about the
incredible detail that this is shedding
on intricate events that are happening
at the edge of a black hole as a neutron
star is swallowed and things like that
can you really glean that much
information about subtle things
happening at that kind of scale just
from such small data from such a trivial
little blip here on Earth
okay I've not heard the liger deaths
have been described in Trivial little
blip but it is like like all it is is
like a flicker it's a flicker a tiny
flicker it is and I realize the
repercussions of it but it doesn't seem
like a lot of information to reconstruct
the Collision of two black holes
absolutely crucial question it's the
question right and um
the the point is remember I mentioned
the template
so the templates what they're really
telling you is you're solving general
relativity equations for two black holes
of some Mass maybe some Spin and you you
believe in general relativity you have
to believe in for this to to work or you
could modify it and do the same thing
and that's also done and you you solve
the equation so the black holes are
merging they're merging they're merging
and what you're predicting out of your
template your Solutions are the
solutions for the gravitational waves
the Distortion of the space time and
what you you actually predict over what
time scale the amplitude and frequency
of that wave should change you have a
very precise prediction for a given set
of masses you present and and there's a
little chirp at the end usually it
happens just as they merge together so
that's your template that's your theory
right you've done it on some big
supercomputer
what the data is doing what the ligo
observatories are doing is they're
measure they're detecting that and they
actually detect over it yeah you're
quite right it's over a relatively short
period of time but they detect the final
infalls of the of the black hole and so
there's a precise they detect a precise
thing and actually a blip at the end
and then what they can do so that's the
data it's got some amplitude and some
frequency over a very short time scale
the the significance of the Precision of
the experiment is really in that it's
just staggering that they can measure
this and have having subtracted out all
the other noise
the the the trend that goes by the you
know the the detector the crocodile that
walks along the ground that must be
producing a vibration bigger than the
radius of a proton atom right proton
nucleus and the fact that they feel they
can do that is the stunning thing the
observation is of some wave
and then what they do is they have a
whole Bank of templates of different
masses of black holes and they're
basically compare you told me about how
some of these findings had actually shot
down a theory that you had hoped may
have some value
to what extent has looking through all
this data got you working on new
theories like how much is it
how much is it affecting your work yeah
I mean it I I have started thinking now
about I've worked on objects which can
be compact they're called oscillons
which can can collapse and and and then
form live for a long time and oscillate
it has made me decide I think we really
need to understand the template of these
objects because they're they're believed
to have been relevant in the early
Universe in fact as the period of
inflation ends they could go through a
period of forming these ocelons
and we've did some initial calculations
of ocelon's orbiting one another but
I've never been been involved in a
project where we've taken it really
seriously and tried to understand the
template and and reading about this
learning about this has made me think
yeah actually I would really like to do
that and the other objects I've always
been interested in and in fact my
wonderful PhD student Despina just
finished her PhD last year on its cosmic
strings and looking at the emission from
cusps of strings and so that's a we've
also been working on that to see whether
or not we can find the template that
that they can use for Liger but liger
already have a very good Bank of people
working on the cosmic strength so that's
kind of already sorted but the ocelons
and those objects not so and I think I'd
love to know about them
what this means but as you can see we've
named them John Paul George and Ringo
okay so so yeah so we sent it off to the
uh to the journal and it immediately
came back without having been assessed
by by any any experts just saying um
there's no way we're going to publish uh
a paper with all these references to the
Beatles in it in view of the Beatles
limited contribution to cosmology